big thank you to Empires and puzzles for
sponsoring today's video over the last
few years in this channel we have
reviewed quite a few of the world's most
popular anime and manga some might call
me an expert others might call me a
professional bad takes Haver but
regardless we have reviewed everything
from Dragon Ball to kjo so I think the
time has finally come for me to rank
each and every one of the stories I've
covered on this channel in one big tier
list the content and selection of which
will likely haunt me for the rest of my
career because taste is a Fickle thing
despite this however I think it could be
a fun trip down memory lane revisiting
some of these great stories to share my
thoughts after so much time having
passed have my judgments remained the
same on these series or have the sands
of time crushed my spirit you'll have to
stay tuned to find out and kicking this
list off fittingly we're beginning with
the story that started it all for me I'm
of course talking about the one the only
Dragon Ball series
[Music]
foreign
Dragon Ball extensively on this channel
there's no hiding it and as many of you
know this series takes many different
forms and in this case ranks in many
different ways depending on which one
you're referring to as a reviewer I've
been fortunate to cover brilliant
stories and while there are aspects I
loved from Dragon Ball GT it is by far
the product I enjoyed the least upon
revisit and review I liked the concept
behind baby and the overall execution of
the arc minus its ending I like the
final Spirit Bomb with kid Goku and
largely I liked the last episode too but
I think that's despite the series more
so than it is a direct result of it with
that said there's clearly a ton of
potential in the series and if you like
it I can sort of see why sort of but for
me when comparing it to other properties
on this list it's a solid detier entry
in saying that while I prefer Dragon
Ball super it isn't much better plagued
early on with two recap arcs possessing
animation so bad it launched my career
here on YouTube it had storylines that
made absolute zero logical sense when
you stop to think about it and even the
parts that are considered the best
material they still are surrounded by
quite a lot of bloat despite this
however I'd be lying if I said super
didn't ignite the kid inside me like
anything else I'm a massive Dragon Ball
fan if it wasn't abundantly clear and
unlike GT I felt super offered more
moments to Rally behind in Praise when
all was said and done I really liked
Ultra Instinct Goku black as a character
was so damn fun and again despite some
truly cursed animation schedules early
on toi was able to deliver some of the
best episodic animation the franchise
had ever seen up until that point plus
some of the new stuff in the manga is
pretty fun too overall I'd rank super
slightly higher than GT maybe a high C
tier now that we've gotten the sequel
series out of the way time to talk about
classic Dragon Ball I loved this story I
love this material and it holds a
special place in my heart I once so
desperately to put it in s tier right
off the bat but let's take a closer look
at things the first Arc is pure 80s
Toriyama gold in all of its Glory it's a
solid first glimpse into the Wacky World
of Dragon Ball so I'd give it a solid a
every and I mean every tournament in
this series is s tier in my opinion
which leaves the Red Ribbon Army ARC and
the King Piccolo Arc the Red Ribbon Army
ARC is fun if but I'd still be inclined
to give it an A or a B but King Piccolo
I've never gelled with personally I find
him largely uninteresting as a villain I
find that the arc is plagued with
problems from contrivances surrounding
Goku's survival during Piccolo and his
first encounter to Goku drinking some
magic water that makes him suddenly
stronger something that actively flies
in the face of a prior lesson Goku
learns during the Red Ribbon Army ARC
funnily enough Toriyama was Ill during
this and while I'm inclined to believe
that impacted the story greatly it can't
exactly change my impression of the arc
overall it is what it is I'd rank it as
C perhaps and so with that all taken
into consideration despite this early
Breezy material containing perhaps my
favorite Arc in the entire series I
can't see it fair to give it anything
more than an a-tier ranking personally
competition is strong so I gotta keep s
tier sacred for now also stay tuned
later this summer for when I for the
first time on this channel reviewed
Dragon Ball Z next up one piece
[Music]
this is the first story I covered on
this channel outside of Dragon Ball and
my God was it a long but brilliant
Adventure spanning across five solid
months and 24 individual review Parts my
review of One Piece was a roller coaster
with me experiencing some of the most
comprehensive revealing and impressively
consistent character in story writing I
had ever been exposed to no manga had
made me cry as frequently and
consistently as one piece which is a
testament to how well Oda realizes and
writes his characters despite often
times being silly or offbeat there are
very few characters in this story that
you could consider truly one-dimensional
with Oda and his team breathing new life
into this world and its inhabitants
wherever they can leading to some of the
most heartbreaking inspiring epic and
action-packed scenes out there for
consumption today in more ways than one
one piece helped to give me the courage
to step out of my comfort zone and
explore new material on my channel and I
honestly don't know where I would be if
I hadn't taken that Leap of Faith with
that said I am in a ruthless mood today
and asked here I don't think is for this
series either while the writing in one
piece is quite literally in a league of
its own there's more to storytelling
when it comes to manga and for me for my
personal tastes oda's paneling
particularly from the halfway point
onward really began to get cluttered and
became at times off-putting for me when
I was making my way through that
material I've had conversations with
folks who say this is a clear s tier
entry and I can't exactly argue against
what they like and enjoy for me though
the panel work holds it back one piece
sits proudly atop a tier and so with one
piece now snugly in the a-tier spot I
wonder will the next one crack the all
too elusive s tier
you are there
[Music]
Hunter Hunter has two relatively popular
adaptations Each of which come with its
own fan bases which makes sense because
both offer very different experiences
and while 2011 lends itself to such
awesome and Whimsical tones thanks to
its color scheme and artistic approach
not to mention that slapping theme song
I think for me it was 99's darker
interpretation of the source materials
manga that offers the most accurate
version of the story plus did you know
that bungeecom has the properties of
both Rubber and gum and I'm a lover of
the 90s animation aesthetic it does
however lose points for not covering
nearly as much material as the 2011
variant which at least feels like it
reaches an end point to some extent but
this is where I'm gonna get a little
introspective here when I dive into my
reviews one of my favorite things to do
is research the author of the material
as best I can to get a better handle on
what exactly they are trying to say in
their stories however when I did this
with tagashi the writer of Hunter Hunter
it opened me up to the tortured painful
full and at times very dark world of a
man struggling to sustain his physical
health long enough to finish the story
that he loves whether it be through
interviews reports or direct text quotes
from the beginning of each individual
manga volume these literal cries for
help I felt began to permeate what was
already a story with a darkness that
resided beneath its surface leading to
one of the darkest feeling clouds
hanging over the conclusion of any
review series I've ever covered when I
throw myself into my work I really try
to immerse myself into the story and the
world and whether it was bad timing
whether it was caused by my research of
tagashi or whether I'm an overly
sensitive person by the time the final
Arc rolled around I felt emotionally
impacted by the material to such an
extent that it literally altered my mood
for the worst during the final stretch
and so I find ranking this particular
story quite difficult it's not like I
haven't covered extremely dark material
on my channel either so my guess is as
good as yours as to why I felt this way
but I do have a theory in the same way I
is viewer can appreciate the astounding
Merit of something like the Lord of the
Rings trilogy without it necessarily
being the sort of story that resonates
with me personally I can also appreciate
how utterly emotionally cataclysmic
something like Hunter Hunter objectively
is for Millions around the world with
that said I don't think tagashi would
say that this series is without
compromise either given his
circumstances and personally even if we
remove the fact that this ants Arc
wasn't for me personally there were some
creative decisions like having the
entire infiltration of the ants Bay
suddenly get presented out of nowhere
through a narrator that I found rather
perplexing and that said the series is
largely brilliant and it made me cry on
more than one occasion so it must have
been doing something very very right
plus the arcs I covered I liked the vast
majority of so I think for Hunter Hunter
I'm comfortable sitting in a top a tier
two so which is gonna be the next one
we're going to tackle on this tier list
Match 3 puzzles are fun enough on their
own but what if you combine them with an
RPG turns out you win a bunch of awards
because that is exactly what Empires and
puzzles did and it is so much fun and
it's free you simply match Shields of
the same color to attack and the more
you match the beefier your attacks will
be but while it's easy to get started
mastering it is a different story making
sure you use your specials at the right
moment is the key to good strategic play
but what also matters are Your Heroes
there are over 400 of these bad boys to
collect with new ones being added every
month they're super critical to play and
with each Victory you'll be using your
rewards to build up their talent trees
and summon even more powerful Heroes if
you're crazy competitive like myself you
can actually hop into PVP and take on
other players for even more rewards it's
a great solo experience but playing with
friends is even better if you invite
your friends along you'll get some sick
rewards for yourself but your friend
will also get a bunch too to help them
catch up so be sure to jump in soon so
you don't miss the upcoming Summer Event
from June 12th to July 16th the game
will be releasing 10 new summer themed
Heroes exclusive event stages and a
bunch of special power-ups it's entirely
free just search Empires and puzzles on
either the IOS app store or the Android
play store and jump in today you'll love
it
[Music]
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure was a weird one
I know that is not a joke this is a
series that very much lived up to the
bizarre in its title and as those of you
that have actually watched this review
series of my no I went into this review
of the manga material with a rather
indifferent or perhaps more accurately a
bad impression of the story from the
famed mangaka araki manga is by faring
away my absolute favorite method of
consuming these stories movies are fine
anime is great and I totally see the
appeal animation and music offers to the
series but I just cannot express how
much better my experience with the story
often is when I consume the material via
the manga I get to control my own pacing
of the events to an extent I enjoy
deconstructing the page layouts to help
me figure out what the author was
thinking and perhaps where he's going
and unfortunately for JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure I watched the anime first and
needless to say it wasn't my bag at all
however when I read the Manga I really
enjoyed the first three or four parts
and funnily enough it was part five the
part that I had to watch instead of read
through that I once again disliked far
more compared to the rest that I read
outside of the material I found within
the confines of the manga I discovered a
tremendous respect for Iraqi through
reading the book he wrote about his life
and indeed the challenges he faced as a
mangaka we're talking about a guy that
had his back against the wall and
instead of following Trends decided to
blaze his own trail fearlessly creating
what is today one of the most prolific
franchises in this industry but despite
my respect for Iraqi I still have to
give my impression on JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure over all that of which I've
read at least I really liked the first
three parts as I said I liked the fourth
well enough though I didn't think it
lived up to the tremendous hype that
people had surrounding it though then
again I don't think it ever could and
the fifth didn't click with me too well
though I didn't enjoy parts of it the
question I think is whether I give this
series a b or an A I'm inclined to give
it a b but only because I was forced to
watch the anime of the fifth part
instead of reading it because the
material hadn't been officially released
yet which admittedly could have changed
my opinion on it in the same way my
opinion had been changed in the first
three parts who knows I might pick this
up and read the material once it's
released in the manga but until then
JoJo exceeded any and all expectations
and sits nicely on B tier which brings
me to
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this one will be interesting to chat
about okay so of the many manga I've
created reviews for this is up there as
one of the very most popular hundreds of
thousands of people watch this series
the vast majority of which were either
quite young or had grown up with that
material I however did neither when I
reviewed the Naruto series I was 30 and
had genuinely not seen a single episode
of the show or chapter of the manga
prior to picking up it first said review
series given that the target audience
was younger than my demo and given that
I was about to experience this story
free of nostalgia I was concerned I
might not resonate with the material in
a way that could be constructive or
entertaining to the viewers I had but
Naruto surprised me not just with a
surprisingly mature subject matter
concerning generational inheritance of
responsibility but additionally in how
Naruto as a character reflected the
agonizing Journey towards success
Kishimoto the author found himself on
this series while I might not have loved
it or resonated with it for the same
reasons I might have when I was 10 years
old like I did with Dragon Ball there
was sufficient heart humor and depth to
these stories and characters that
genuinely ignited my imagination in a
way that held my attention from
beginning to end I really don't think I
can ask for much more than that with a
story like this I had some issues with
it as I read along and my god did some
characters I won't name names make some
questionable decisions which created
contrived conflict I will still however
award this series an a tier I really did
enjoy the vast vast majority of it and
it even managed to squeeze a few tears
out of me while my guide was down but
yeah that's Naruto next up is
[Applause]
I'm gonna try to keep this one really
quick and concise given I have not yet
completed the story proper but while I
am here I will award this series a spot
on B tier while I await the time for me
to review the Thousand Years blood War
which might be the most metal Arc title
I've ever heard I love the heart behind
this series I love the plot Direction
and growth for the character of Ichigo
and the artwork is something else unlike
more crowded and exhausting reads like
One Piece bleach's manga manages to stay
Breezy and fun to read by keeping things
stunningly Illustrated utilizing white
space and always keeping page layout at
the Forefront of their minds with that
said I do think that some of the acts
namely the irankar are could have been
significantly shorter without impacting
the plot much at all and they might have
even seen some benefits by doing so I
get that a lot of folks must love the
fight scenes in the series and that's
cool by me I'm glad that you like it but
after tens and tens of chapters of what
felt like the same thing over and over
again I felt that the pacing could have
been helped greatly had a greater
emphasis being placed on story over the
finding itself perhaps I just have an
entirely different taste in manga to
most bleach friends and that is very
possible the full bring Arc was honestly
my favorite Arc out of the entire read
and ironically that isn't the case with
the greater fan base it was concise it
was mysterious and the artwork was
outstanding it even got me excited for
what was to come next so yeah for now I
think it's cool to place this on B tier
but who knows it might go up after I
finish reading the next ACT next up
[Music]
this story is still fresh in my mind
having just finished it a couple of
weeks ago as I'm writing this video but
man does this story feel like it was
perfectly conceived of Illustrated
written and delivered to my eyes this is
a story that lives up to every single
last ounce of hype surrounding it it
destroyed me emotionally captured my
imagination with its world and offered
plenty to talk about week in and week
out while I was reading and reviewing it
this is a story that's built such a
powerful Foundation that there are two
entirely different interpretations of
the story that have their own
independent fan bases that swear their
version is the best over the other I
don't think I've ever come across an
instance where this has been the case
with a given story and if you watch my
review series concerning it you'll
notice that I too struggled to find
fault with this material which is why
I'm confident that this one can sit
nicely as our first s tier entry and by
the looks of it with our next entry
Fullmetal Alchemist might be getting
some company up there
[Music]
you and me
every single time I review a story on
this channel it comes with a flood of oh
my God you're gonna love this series I
just know it it's the best and what I do
normally as this tier list will reflect
love the stories I cover there are very
few that actually live up to that hype
100 and maybe there's just one other
that did that made it to this level of
wow it feels as though this series was
Tailor Made For Me mob psycho 100 is an
emotional series it's a hilarious series
hell this is just a terrific show from
top to bottom everything from the themes
explored to the broken characters that
take Center Stage for us to watch as
they struggle through their lives and
grow from the traumas they encounter
collectively out of every other single
anime on this list this stands as by far
my favorite it ruined me emotionally at
the finish of each and every season it
knew exactly what it wanted to say and
it did not overstay its welcome like so
many others I could argue are guilty for
also the music can we just talk about
the music for a second the old peas to
this series were phenomenal but I think
the OST gets overlooked sometimes here
the strange instrumentation that Echoes
each and every one of mob's power boosts
is to this day able to bring Shivers to
my skin it's just such an incredible
series and if it wasn't obvious already
I liked it even more than Full Metal
Alchemist if that was even possible if
you haven't checked it out please do
Reagan is awesome and next up something
a little stranger
chainsaw man is a weird one to rank as
unlike most previous entries on this
list I've actually seen both the anime
and manga versions and with this story
each version offers a very different
experience despite covering the same
material with the manga we get pure
unfiltered and hilarious Fujimoto in all
of his glory and things get really weird
hilarious but extremely weird and while
I would say that the anime adaptation is
largely enjoyable it is so in a very
different way to that which fujimoto's
pure version might demonstrate the anime
itself is clearly directed by an
individual with a distinct and obvious
vision for how he sees things ought to
be and that's fair this is how he sees
chainsaw man and so who am I to say that
he's wrong if this is what he sees when
he watches it it's not like it doesn't
look outstanding at times and offers a
ton in its own right it absolutely does
but what I will say is that what I love
about chainsaw man's manga was that it
felt entirely new unlike anything I'd
ever read before like the latest
iteration of older ideas that came
before it plays with shapes ideas
choreography and pacing in such a
frenetic fashion all the while
presenting it in some of the most
imaginative ways I've ever seen put to
paper this is all to say the chainsaw
man's manga feels distinctly its own
thing while the anime feels sort of like
it's trying to be like something else
something that already exists which
might be unfair but that's just how I
felt after having watched it again
massively enjoyed it just not in the
same way I thought I would that said the
manga is outstanding so I think I'll
slot chainsaw man in on a tier
problem
[Music]
foreign
there's a reason this wasn't a review
series there's a reason I wrote a near
three hour long review of this story
there's a reason why it's the most
viewed video on my entire Channel by far
it's because I had to gush and I loved
it so damn much that I had to make what
was at the time the biggest review on my
channel also I really liked the idea of
calling this review the Colossal review
and I stand by that decision it was all
worth the effort just so that I could
have one massive video with that title I
started watching this series as it came
out back in 2013 and I had kept up with
it all the way to the ending and don't
worry I won't be sharing any spoilers
here just my general thoughts but in
short I don't think any other series on
this list got me as excited to pick up
and read the Manga more than this story
did it's so well crafted and conceived
and while I know there are those out
there that don't enjoy some part of it I
loved it all with that said I didn't
read the extended bonus chapter isayama
wrote after the series had technically
finished outright and I feel like if I
do I might not like it as much given
people's reception about it so yeah if
you don't like that I didn't read it I
don't care this is going to be S tier
moving on
I didn't cover this story so much in a
review as I did analyze the greater
story in general in a single shorter
video so I'll keep this one equally
short this is one of the first anime I
watched while understanding what anime
was in the first place it's a classic
one that no doubt has stripped the
social life of many adolescents myself
included but you know what the first
half of the story is so damn good it
almost made it worth it and to be honest
I'm one of the few out there that
actually quite enjoyed the second half
too but however even with that second
half being a little lackluster compared
to the first the ending that we landed
on was Sensational and the overall
measures of the piece was very
interesting if I was just considering
the first half with L and the ending on
its own it'd be a shoe-in for S tier but
alas I need to stick it in the bottom of
a tier maybe B tier I'm gonna put an
eight here and so now the time has come
for the best Manga I've ever reviewed on
this channel drum roll please berserk
[Music]
thank you
I finished reading and reviewing berserk
well over a year ago and I swear to you
all right now not a day goes by without
me thinking about a lesson I learned
from this story at least once per day
there is quite literally nothing like
this story on the market today nothing
that can remotely come close to the
Colossal effort this manga boasts I mean
this is quite literally the life's work
of the now late great kintaro meora
flick through to a random page in this
manga and you'll no doubt discover a
panel are too worthy of being a poster
or mural on a wall where so much of the
stories I cover deal with similar
subject matters surrounding adolescence
there's a few lessons in here that I
think everyone would benefit from
learning at any point in their lives and
experiencing through this book
particularly if you might have troubling
or distant relationship with your
parents and or feel isolated I won't
dare spoil a single word of this for any
of you out there but this is the manga
that literally changed my outlook on
life for the better and to say that it's
an S tier entry almost seems
unsatisfactory it almost deserves more
so if you haven't seen it I beg you to
give it a shot I know you won't regret
it this is the best Manga on this list
and I can't imagine anything will top
this
[Music]
foreign
be sure to download Empires and puzzles
on either Apple's app store or Android's
Play Store
[Music]
thank you